[Musique]
cette année le parc des buttes chaumont
à 100 ans c'est un âge respectable même
pour un jardin et depuis sa naissance il
a eu le temps de soulever bien des
admirations et bien des critiques
c'est finalement l'admiration qui semble
l'avoir emporté
[Musique]
on peut sourire de trouver en plein
paris ces surprenantes falaise
verdoyante
c'est brottes c'est rock déchiqueter ce
lac qui dresse le décor baroque des
opéras bouffe du second empire
mais lorsqu'on le juge il ne faut jamais
oublier qu'il masque sous les apparences
futile ceux qui durant des siècles ne
fut qu'un lieu de misère et de mort
[Musique]
chaumont vient sans doute du latin
calvus monde mon show qui désigne une
colline d'argile ou de gypse impropres à
toute culture en 885 elle entre dans
l'histoire
les normands envahissent la france et
c'est aux buttes-chaumont que le comte
eudes alors gouverneur de paris
s'opposent à leur avance à la tête de la
milice parisien un combat inégal se
déroule contre ces hordes féroce et
puissamment armés qui ont déjà mis à sac
saint denis et se prépare à faire subir
le même sort à la capitale
[Musique]
après plusieurs heures d'âpres combats
l'ennemi est repoussée la ville sauvé et
les normands se retire en laissant plus
de 19000 mort sur le champ de bataille
c'est la victoire de montfaucon trois
siècles plus tard enguerrand de marigny
assure à cenon une célébrité de moins
bon aloi est celui qui sur l'ordre de
philippe le bel fit élever le fameux
jbeil où il allait lui même être pendus
ou s'est il contenté de le réparer les
avis diffèrent mais ce qui est certain
c'est que l'ombre sinistre des fourches
patibulaires planeront durant des
siècles sur ce coin de terre déjà
déshérités
[Musique]
les poids de justice sont ils les seuls
à trouver le moyen de s'élever sur cette
terre ingrate
en 1761 non loin du premier jb de
montfaucon on en élève un second plus
petit est réservé et plus spécialement
aux bandits de grand chemin aux voleurs
et aux condamnés de droit commun
on y expose plus les coupables mais les
piliers et leur disposition ont été
conservés comme signe de la justice
royale
la révolution qui leur préfèrent la
guillotine et fera à battre et à leur
place s'étendront une voirie est une
entreprise d'équarrissage
c'est ici désormais au milieu de
baraquements sordide que va s'achever
l'existant de tous les chevaux vieux
blessés malades ou hors d'état de servir
certaines années on en a battra jusqu'à
15 mhz leur peau seront envoyés aux
tanneurs leur crinière venduoo bourlier
et au tapissier on confectionnera des
cordes avec leurs boyaux et l'on
abandonnera après les carcasses inutile
bientôt attirés par cette nourriture
gratuite des milliers de rats pullulent
creusant le sol d'innombrables galant on
raconte qu en une nuit il se chargeait
de transformer une carcasse
sanguinolente en un squelette propre et
bien nettoyer outre les boyauderie
s'élève peu à peu des entreprise
cultivant les asticots pour la pêche ou
transformant les ordures de la voirie en
un engrais appelé poudenx lempire ne
changera rien à cet état de choses
[Applaudissements]
mais au début 2008 114 lorsque les
armées coalisées des forces européennes
envahissent la france et que les
vingt-deux mille hommes qui défendent
paris se prépare à faire face aux deux
cent mille hommes des armées ennemies
c'est sur les hauteurs des buttes
chaumont que se livrent la bataille
décisive
l'action commence alors elle se poursuit
avec acharnement la plus grande partie
de la journée
six fois les troupes commandées par le
général marmont le général compan et le
duc de raguse repousse les assauts
ennemis
les élèves de l'école polytechnique
servent les quelques pièces de canon et
préfèrent se faire tuer sur place plutôt
que de reculer
c'est alors que marmont qui veut éviter
apparaît une destruction certaine se
décide à arrêter les combats
signé chez un marchand de la villette
qui portent l'enseigne du petit jardinet
la capitulation lui fut pourtant
durement reproche après son retour de
l'île d'elbe napoléon qui veut se mettre
à l'abri d'une nouvelle invasion
entourent paris d'un réseau de
fortifications et en élève naturellement
sur les hauteurs des buttes chaumont
elle ne lui éviteront pas une nouvelle
défaite et c'est la restauration le
village de lacour qui y est devenu un
lieu de plaisir et à belleville
s'élèvent des montagnes russes mais les
buttes chaumont continuent leurs obscurs
existence
[Musique]
elles sont à présent minet comme une
vaste opine hier par des carrières qui
entrelace leur galerie sur plusieurs
étages ont dans l'extrait lachaud le
plâtre le sable et la pierre à bâtir
c'est de là qu'on a tiré les blocs qui
servent de soubassement à la statue de
la liberté qui se dressent dans le port
de new york
aussi at-on pris l'habitude de les
désigner sous le nom de carrière d'amy
[Musique]
on
pour
mais ces souterrains souvent abandonnés
servent aussi de refuge à la pègre
c'est l'asile naturelle écrit balzac de
la misère et du désespoir elle abrite
une véritable cour des miracles qui la
nuit fait ripaille avec les marchandises
dérobées et dont de fréquentes descentes
de police ne peuvent venir à bout
belleville et les buttes chaumont font
partie de paris depuis 1860 et napoléon
iii b sides d'assainir le quartier et
demande à alphand de créer à la place de
ces carrières un vaste jardin
les travaux durent trois ans commencée
en 1864 il s'achève en 1867 pour
l'ouverture de l'exposition universelle
très intelligemment alphand aidé par le
jardinier en chef de la ville de paris
barillet profite de la nature accidentée
du terrain
il utilise pour faire une grotte
l'entrée d'anciennes carrières taille
les flancs accidenté de la butte exécute
sur 27 hectares plus de 800 mille mètres
cubes de terrassement à porte avec 100
chevaux et 1000 ouvriers
plus de deux cent mille mètres cubes de
terre végétale ces travaux devaient
coûter quatre millions cinq cent mille
francs or somme considérable pour
l'époque en partie financés sur la
cassette personnelle de napoléon iii
le nouveau jardin avait la forme d'un
croissant percée de six portes
[Musique]
au centre c'est un lac d'une superficie
de deux hectares
[Musique]
ils entourent une falaise abrupte haute
de 50 mètres que deux pont relie à la
berge et que couronne un belvédère
inspiré par les grecs
il rappelle tout à la fois le temple de
vesta à tivoli et le monument de l'isie
crainte a atteint située à 90 mètres au
dessus du niveau de la mer c'est un des
points culminants de la capitale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une grotte s'ouvre dans la muraille que
domine la rue botzaris
[Musique]
elle mesure 22 mètres de haut et sa
voûte est tapissé de faux stalactites de
8 et 9 m
[Musique]
au milieu de la grotte tombe de 32 m une
cascade qui alimente un des ruisseaux
qui se jette dans le
le jardin futile inauguré le 1er avril
1867 date d'ouverture de l'exposition
universelle où le 1er mai suivant peu
importe
trois ans plus tard c'est la guerre
paris est assiégé les sentinelles
montent la garde sur les hauteurs des
buttes chaumont ont fait que devant les
boulangeries
devant les bouchons
un parc d'artillerie a été rassemblée
sur les escarpements qui domine le
jardin
[Musique]
tandis que le lac lui ait été transformé
en un gigantesque dépôt de pétrole
accident imprudence sabotage au début
d'octobre 1870 l'énorme réservoir prend
feu et on a bien du mal à éteindre le
brasier avec les moyens dérisoires dont
on nous coupe
puis c'est la commune la semaine
sanglante maintenant c'est paris tout
entier qui brûle
le mouvement révolutionnaire qui a pris
naissance sur la butte montmartre va
mourir à belleville pied à pied on
défend les barricades élevé à chaque
carrefour
[Musique]
rue haxo les fédérer qui se savent père
du fusil en block 52 zotac
les versaillais poursuivre les
communards jusque dans le jardin des
buttes chaumont
plus tard il le transformeront en un
énorme camps de concentration pour y
garder leurs prisonniers
[Musique]
et le rideau tombe sur tant de drames la
belle époque a maintenant huit
l'histoire du jardin n'est plus rythmé
que par des rires d'enfants et par la
chute du haut du pont de pierre qui
prend le nom de pont des suicides et de
quelques maniaques du désespoir
[Musique]
mais les anciennes carrières vont de
nouveau faire parler d'elle reposant sur
un sol instable et miner le fond du
bassin menace de s'effondrer sous le
poids des eaux
aujourd'hui d'énormes travaux ont été
entrepris par la conservation des parcs
et jardins on à vider l'eau du lac qui
reposera désormais sur un quadrillage de
ciment soutenu par des piliers allant
chercher le sol ferme jusqu'à 15 et 20
mètres de profondeur la grotte a été
fermé la cascade arrête son os
s'infiltrait dans les galeries
souterraines minant le sol et menaçant
les fondations de la mairie du 19e
arrondissement et des immeubles proches
[Musique]
bientôt les travaux en cours seront
terminés
une moitié du lac est déjà achevée
l'autre très prochainement puis ce sera
le tour de la côte et le jardin des
buttes chaumont retrouvera l'éclat de sa
jeunesse et de sa beauté
[Musique]